it's a movie about a final Reckoning  between Lori and Michael  Myers in that mask represents Pure Evil  there is no Rhyme or Reason  what are you gonna do when Michael comes  back to me because he is coming  everybody's worst nightmare come to life  you came here to kill me so do it  this experience in the movies  that is the beauty of Halloween  in 1978 I had no idea what the worldwide  love and affection for Lori Strode and  Michael Myers would be  that is the heart and soul of these  Halloween movies  it will be difficult to say goodbye to  Lori Strode it's her Legacy and it's now  part of ours for New Years with this  character Jamie Lee Curtis of Halloween  thank you  it feels very special to me